welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and I don't know
about you guys but I'm still thinking
about Janet's response to the quantum
realm Scott wrote an entire book about
his journey to the QR and according to
endgame he only felt about five hours
past while trapped inside during the
blip Jada lived down there for decades
and she outright refused to discuss her
time in the pocket Dimension with her
family despite the fact that her
knowledge could have prepared the laying
slash Pim slash Van Dyne fam for their
Quest why was Janet so much more keen to
venture back into the quantum realm in
previous films today I'm breaking down
Janet's relationship with the QR to
speculate on her true feelings about her
time spent inside and look I get it the
simple answer is that Janet was written
this way because it worked out better
for the plot Whitney we saw something
similar happen to Wanda's character in
Multiverse of Madness although she made
a lot of positive progress towards
accepting the loss of her family at the
end of one division Mom saw her decline
back into grief to move the mcu's plot
forward but Janet's trajectory is
equally baffling and fascinating let's
start at the beginning in the first
Ant-Man we learned that back in 1987
Janet and Hank left young hope at home
while they flew off to disengage a
Soviet missile head for the United
States in order to break through the
icb's titanium outer shell Janet turned
off her Quantum regulator allowing her
to go subatomic to slip through the
cracks unfortunately she was lost to the
quantum realm too small to return but in
ants too we learned that Janet actually
found a way to communicate with Scott in
the aftermath of his brief time in the
quantum realm when he went subatomic to
defeat Darren cross at the end of ants
one Janet forms a quantum entanglement
with his Consciousness this neuro
connection allows her to convey messages
to Scott all the way from the quantum
realm sending him her memories as
Visions whenever a tunnel to the quantum
realm is online after hope and Hank
create a stable portal to rescue her she
fully possesses Scott's body allowing
her to physically speak through him and
even perform tasks used in his meat suit
she's like a tiny insect version of the
demon from The Exorcist minus all the
head spinning and vomiting on priests
and stuff let's face it after a night
with with drinks I don't bounce back the
next day like I used to I started
feeling like I had to make a choice have
an IPA at trivia night or skip my
morning job that is until I found
zebiotics cbiotics pre-alcohol probiotic
is the world's first genetically
engineered probiotic it was invented by
PhD scientists to tackle rough mornings
after drinking here's how it works when
you drink alcohol gets converted into a
toxic byproduct in the gut it's this
byproduct not dehydration that's to
blame for your rough next day zibiotics
produces an enzyme to break this
byproduct down it's designed to work
like your liver but in your gut where
you need it most just remember to drink
zebiotics before drinking alcohol drink
responsibly and get a good night's sleep
to feel your best tomorrow give
zebiotics a try for yourself go to
zebiotics.com new rockstars or scan the
QR code on the screen right now to get
15 off your first order when you use new
rock stars at checkouts abiotics is
backed with a hundred percent money back
guarantee so if you're unsatisfied for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked just head to
zebiotics.com new rockstars and use the
code new rockstars at checkout for 15
off thank you zebiotics for sponsoring
this episode using Scott as a puppet
Janet is even able to input her exact
coordinates in the QR pinpointing the
specific location where Hank and health
needed to scoop her up after Janet
returns to 616 and uses her Quantum
energy to stabilize Ava star's molecular
disequilibrium the group of four set to
work creating an even better more stable
portal back to the quantum realm Janet
instructed Scott to make a quick trip
Harvest some medicinal Quantum energy
for Ava and return without being eaten
by tardigrades but unfortunately Thanos
snaps Hank Janet and hope out of
existence before they can bring him back
so here's where my questions begin why
was Janet okay with communicating with
Scott from the quantum realm and Ant-Man
and the WASP but isn't cool with Cassie
sending a signal down there in
quantumania this one is relatively easy
to answer and comes down to movie
science while Hank describes Cassie's
Quantum mapping device as a subatomic
Hubble Telescope Cassie's explanation
proves that it's less of an optical
telescope like the Hubble and more of a
sonar mapping device or a radio
telescope like echolocation Cassie is
sending constant signals all across the
QR so that she can build a map based on
how they bounce back so while Cassie's
Quantum telescope sent and received
signals from the QR akin to a two-way
radio as she simplifies it Janet was
essentially communicating with Scott on
a one-way radio when Janet Is possessing
Scott hope actually makes the
observation that she put an antenna in
Scott's head basically a one-way
receiver Scott wasn't able to send
messages back to Janet it's not like
they were having to and fro
conversations with one another she was
sending him visions and messages until
[__] started to hit the fan and it
became absolutely necessary for her to
Pilot his body because she was sending
out a one-way signal in the past I think
that that's why she was okay with prior
communication from the quantum realm
furthermore Scott Janet actually does
show concern about the atomic
frequencies the pims use once they start
pinpointing her location in the quantum
ROM Hank suggests that they track her
transmission using subatomic frequencies
which between 0.2 and 0.9 and she tells
him to tweak them down to 0.4 and 0.6
while Hank insists that that range is
too narrow Janet pushes back and
ultimately Hank agrees to tighten the
range to 0.3 and 0.7 now why would Janet
want to reduce the amount of frequencies
they're scanning possibly because
they're scanning Tech the same Tech that
Cassie studied for her device used
similar to a sonar Tech that outputs
signals in order to pinpoint locations
is it possible that Janet wanted them to
reduce their scanned frequencies not
only to speed up her extraction but also
to limit the possible frequencies Kane
could catch them on it didn't make sense
that Janet would want them to make the
smallest footprint possible when
touching down into the QR Janet also set
a time limit for her family once they
had her coordinates they only had a two
hour window to find her before her
location shifted in space-time according
to her she would be a century away if
they missed her exact location but I
actually think it's possible that Janet
set a timer for another reason perhaps
in addition to time displacement she was
worried that came would intercept their
Journey if her family took too long to
find her by keeping their jump into the
quantum realm quiet and short they'd
minimize any blips they'd make on Kang's
radar Cassie's machine on the other hand
has a huge sprawling microverse to map
and likely has to do the opposite to
work optimally and once that machines
made enough noise during any of its test
runs Modoc would know what to look for
when it turned back on here's another
question though why was Janet totally
cool with Scott venturing back into the
QR to fetch more Quantum energy the only
thing she warns him about is running
into tardigrades she just lets her
pseudo sudden law go on a Postmates
errand to pick up a Quantum energy
prescription for a girl who tried to
murder him in a realm where she knows
that Kang's abs are in charge you could
argue that the quantum realm is
unknowably huge and that Kang might not
get a notification from his Quantum ring
doorbell every single time any being
enters this vast reality but how is she
able to find Scott without having
previously met him did she build some
sort of notification device to alert her
if Hank's suit ever entered the quantum
realm was it just dumb luck that she was
at the same point in the QR as Scott and
even dumber luck that she had the tech
or power to place an antenna into his
head or maybe it wasn't just dumb luck
remember Janet touched Kang's
neurokinetic chair and got a glimpse
into his mind this means that Janet was
able to seamlessly interface with his
Tech in that moment Tech that Kang uses
to observe and Traverse timelines is it
possible that somehow through his time
observing or probability analyzing Tech
she was able to briefly see an
alternative way out of the QR just
enough to know roughly where to be and
what to do to escape my head Canon is
that her sole focus and desire to get
home to Hope mixed briefly with King's
Tech and she was imprinted with a vision
or path that would make that happen
similar to how Scott and hope coming
together in the probability storm
reduced all possibilities to one Janet's
determination and focus allowed her to
turn a possibility into a reality but
why was Janet so cagey about explaining
her adventures or acts of terrorism
depending on who you ask in the quantum
realm like I get why she didn't want to
admit that she Bill Murray yeesh but why
didn't she warn her family about Kang
obviously she was ashamed of the fact
that she nearly helped him Escape but
she could have skirted around that part
at least like hey guys don't send a
two-way signal to the quantum realm
because there's a bad guy down there who
might get loose if you do it would have
sufficed if she just didn't want to tell
him the truth it does seem odd that she
freaked out harder about her adoptive
granddaughter's Quantum cartography than
she did about Scott dipping into the
realm for a double scoop of quantum
energy and again the simple answer is
because this was a plot contrivance to
put quantumania's story and emotion I
admit that I could totally be reading
way too much into this but just for
funsies what if there's another reason
why Janet grew more paranoid and closed
off about discussing the quantum realm
with her family what if Janet had
started to receive signals from the
quantum realm like the ones she used to
send to Scott I don't think that Kang
possessed her body or anything like that
but perhaps here Modoc found a way to
neuro connect to Janet from the QR like
she did back in ants too a possible
quantum entanglement with Kang or
another quantum and T could explain why
Janet grew increasingly fearful of the
QR after all Cassie and Hank were
experimenting with the two-way Quantum
radio prior to her showing it off to the
rest of the family someone from the
quantum realm could have become Quantum
entangled with Janet when she arrived
back into the 616 in Ant-Man 2. just
like she had with Scott after Ant-Man 1.
like I mentioned earlier Janet initially
sent Scott messages in his dreams such
as visions of her and hope playing hide
and seek in a wardrobe perhaps she began
having similar dreams when Cassie
started her initial tests and that's
when she started clamming up about the
QR kind of like Scott coming to the
realization things definitely aren't
fine at the end of quantumania those
dreams could have shattered the safe
fantasy world that she convinced herself
she was living in it's possible that
this Epiphany could have triggered the
traumatic memories from being on the run
from King in the QR and her response to
questions about the QR was to avoid this
topic entirely these are just some of my
theories about Janet's experience with
King in the quantum realm but I want to
know what you guys think in the comments
why do y'all think she avoided telling
Hank hope Cassie and Scott about the
Conqueror follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at whitneypuppy follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign